[موسيقى]
قبل وبعد هكذا تشوهت باخمت في عام ملامح
مدينه طمست بعد اشهر من القصف
صور للاقمار الصناعيه اظهرت دمارا احدثته
الحرب بين الثامن من مايو الماضي حتى
اليوم
في عمق الصوره الجانب الشمالي من مدينه
باخموت منطقه المستشفى الحكومي عده مدارس
هكذا اصبحت في عام لاكثر
وهنا المنطقه الشرقيه تعرف بالاكثر حيويه
ولسوء حظها كانت الاكثر استهدافا ايضا تضم
سكنه عسكريه وفندقا شهيرا ومنازل
اما وسط المدينه يتميز بطابعه الاداري
والثقافي اما الان مبان اداريه ومسارح
فنيه مدمره
الثقافه ممتده الى هنا ايضا منطقه تعج
بالجامعات والمعاهد والمعابد لم تبقي
الحرب شيئا منها
صور من العلو لكن الحال لا يختلف كثيرا عن
الارض معارك لا زالت على اشدها بعد تسعه
اشهر من المواجهات فيما المسافه القليله
تبقى عصيه على السيطره
تشتد وتيره المعارك الان واشدد على ان لم
تسقط في اليومين المقبلين تبقى اقل من
كيلو متر واحد منطقه ساما لوت حصن منيع
يحول دون السيطره الكامله حتى الان وفق
باجنر
بينما يحقق الجيش الاوكراني مكاسبه
ميدانيا على اطراف باخمت ضمن مقاومه
عسكريه مضاده تستعد لها كييف بعتاد غربي
غذاء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات